ya can't fix it so 15 seconds until
kickoff let's see what we're gonna have
here we go let's try and confuse this
guy how clever that was what a mouse
slipped to start Bishop here pile up on
this pun take three pawns take this one
he's free too isn't he
the knight is pinned I could take you
with my bishop there is no Knight b6
space advantage stop Knight b6 I want to
just complete my development get my
bishop out get castled get this beep on
rollin let me take here first get rid of
this guy he's bad news actually let's
get rid of this Knight maybe not let's
just get the majority going pawn
majority get rolling here keep going
pawn up to a for my queen looks like
she's running out of squares but she
should be safe I could drop back let's
drop back now that that be pawn is
supported let's come here I was gonna go
there for a second let's just stay out
of any tricky stuff Bishop here passed
pawn this pawn is gonna be targeted next
I should have just taken it take it next
pretty much no matter what skewer take
the rook no matter what actually he's
not going anywhere
pawn push is even better don't take pin
pieces attack them there's a deadly fork
everything is hit everything is hit
double attack on the Queen look here the
queen is dead and new queen is on the
scene
drop the knight back let's just take
that tricky Knight I just said drop the
knight back multiple Queens everywhere
down on time back to tournament 6
somebody has 6 and a bunch of two's bit
squared last time I got clever with the
name like that
I got mated very quickly all right um
okay I was gonna do Queen c7 let's not
can I get a b7 dark square weaknesses
can I take advantage of that night here
I end up pinning it and hit it twice
let's see how they defend the Queen
Bishop here induced this pawn move and
now this is a target drop back get my
knight to c6 get castled maybe a pawn
push well those guys aren't gonna go
anywhere I can't get that advancing my
bishop needs help okay
Queens are off the board my favorite I
can't do that I'm on the bishop my
knight is good this is a week's crack
this Bishop is loose bishop here seems
appealing this one seems good to Bishop
here I think I'd do this advance maybe I
can get these two pawns going pick up
the bishop pair this guy is still doing
absolutely nothing I want to do f6 e 5
to knock out these two keep in mind this
particular structure works very good
against a knight on that so this
classical square and a bishop right next
to it so that structures is uh is very
very good so Knight here I'm prepared to
just give up my bishop fine without you
could play bishop here next and I'm
looking for just some trades these guys
again are out of play
keep one rook on the board one rook is
good they're actually down on time so it
just does not matter no time back to
tournament six
somebody has 12 12 9 oh I thought I had
I think I saw Anton squared I got
distracted I thought I was gonna be
playing against a Natanz squared and I
was gonna be having to defend against f2
or f7 can I have a quick kill I'm on the
Queen that's me Oh back to tournament 12
12 9 I needed that Oh deadly Knight f6
deadly Knight f6 star square weaknesses
25 seconds remaining surfer surfer let's
try something else
d5 no matter what now II five no map no
B 5 no matter what actually not no
matter what no can I get some pressure
okay that's a free pawn back up and hang
on to this guy however pawn plush is not
there so I'm up I'm just up a full pun
now this Knights getting kicked around I
just want to develop and take that open
up this diagon for my queen open up the
a file from me if there's a capture okay
my Queen wants to play I'm gonna take I
want a king in on my tricky Knight Queen
here might be a threat if the knight
moves he moved but but what let's do
this they're just Castle oh oh they
could have taken the night they would
have been on my rook forgot that little
detail I need to get my development
complete here I don't care but I want to
get this structure and drop back so I
can recapture with my clean I still want
to just get developed I want to grab
that pond
don't take with my queen keep my rook
around let's take this I don't keep
those pawns aren't gonna do anything are
they why am I not moving oh I have a
fork right here but there's rook takes
first Queen check pick up that pawn get
rid of this Knight first 14 seconds what
does that move even do works me into a
pin for one this is this is a very
reckless move by the way that last mold
I did very very reckless pawn push
Knight right here is gonna be deadly
that pond has passed but I have a tricky
named tricky Knight there's also very
little time anything that was not a good
move by me what am i doing time burn is
god-awful that look very ugly hopefully
you weren't looking directly at the
kingside things could turn out very ugly
sometimes and that was it I was ugliness
confuse ray is back he's back
main line Carol not the opening you want
to play in these games these Bullock
games oh hang on hang on we're looking
for mates here tricky mates on ff7 boom
I confuse ray now I didn't confuse them
he just he was in prima love I think I
know I could definitely relate to that I
found for this scholars mate I found for
the scholars me okay gambit land some
gambit okay I'm getting an e5 and now I
want to put pressure on f2 maybe jump in
here hit the Queen okay know what what's
what's what's going on okay I did this
so that there is no Queen takes pawn
right now with check so now I have a
fork King has to go there it's gonna
grab here yes mm-hm this might be scary
might not be scary to oh but that even
mean right there hang on Queenie seven
Queen to e7 it might be scary and it
might not be scary you could say that
out no matter what can you let's do this
oh where is he running to he's running
away
okay the Knights in a pen I want to get
out of pins so my Bishop can move
there's gonna be deadly for Knight d4 is
gonna happen isn't it I need to rescue
my knight he's in the corner he's stuck
bishop check just player here Knight d4
has to be good doesn't it let's see my
d4 I have my pick pick your favorite
Knight to move to d4 one of them is
gonna be good
tricky checks however you slice it
okay now I'm hitting the rook and the
pitcher Bishop's going down rook here
free piece forks on c3 Forks on c3
Primos no time back to terminate 40 to
30 30 Bank oh geez up there 21 minutes
remaining level four Kings gambit Vienna
game oh my goodness f3
what a wonderful start a wonderful start
I got to kill this Knight he's gonna
cause me some problems if I don't get
rid of him
gotta get rid of this Bishop next all
because of a silly little f3 move
oh just Swiss cheese over here doubled
pawns Knight right here okay this bishop
had this pawn needs to go otherwise the
bishop gets to camp out here I have
pressure against H my knight wants to be
here now get rid of that light square
Bishop whoa
giving up the bishop pair attacking my
rook on up I don't want to cast yeah I
better Castle what else am I gonna do
let's do this I'm opposite the clean
pawn push come over here
my Knights gonna be in a pin soon okay I
get a piece or not a piece of pond feels
like a piece though this Knight is a
monster control over this could take
that Bishop out get my pawns working
this is a three to two majority more
trades this is a one King and pawn
endgame
just take that I have to win this king
upon endgame now King position King
position King position there's no way to
create a passed pawn unless there's a
mouse live here so get these pawns
working pretty soon it's my C pawn whose
becomes passed 16 seconds keep going and
I think when it comes to stalemate I
think I just well now I don't have to
have that issue because of how the Kings
how the King moved so there is a move by
the King and I'm able to get a clean ten
seconds and are they gonna resign 15
seconds 14 they resigned back to
terminate 5655 42:35 John
man is up there Oh John Madden is back
John Madden
ok it's worked well last time black my
redeemer I'm gonna take this gambit I'm
gonna take that pun should just take
that night and now that bishops gonna be
wild he's gonna be wild isn't he
it's a little scary right now I have to
say pawn push ok pawn push now and I
just jumped there I want to make sure I
have control over the white squares
guard this square Oh this pawn is
dropping ok a little scary
it's pawn is still dropping pawn push
can I get that in if Queen takes pawn
edge is Castle there King is weak I want
to their King is weak I'm defending this
now I want to remove this pawn but as
soon as I move it this nights gonna jump
in and kill me let's remove it with this
pond hologram I somehow didn't want to
allow this night to jump in there so
they're gonna take this on their Bishop
okay happy to actually see that I just
want to open up this diagonal just want
to open up that diagonal get that [ __ ]
back there there's Queen checks my
knight is very tricky
not just my night every night is tricky
Queen check the bishop is dead and now
where's the for I just throw in another
check just for fun
hang on deadly Fork deadly fork to take
otherwise it's another fork
Queen here no matter what no time either
clean is dad skewer no time back to
Chairman 72 5653 not even at the halfway
point oh man
nap three I think the last time I played
nap nap beat me now put me to sleep
stick around that is not the last joke
that is not the last bad joke you will
hear I promise you that oh hang on more
bad jokes to come more bad jokes ah
they're looking to me they're looking to
make me here this night is such a pain
he needs to get out of there
he's not going anywhere
I got to take like I don't know how I
have to take I have to watch over this
pond clean is just too strong I don't
want to be tethered to the defense here
and now let me get these bishops out of
here you guys need to go guys definitely
need to go take my night I don't take my
night I have this covered so I could
take this is defended on d1 they miss
that I'm there to defend otherwise that
is the correct type of thing to do so
now support this and get my bishop
pointing at B supports e5 Bishop to f3
pin point B oh no that pawn can't be
caught fortunately he his bishops boxing
out the night that's good news okay just
drop back King position King position
I'll be able to push that pawn through
back to tournament they resigned 90-72
69 56 John Madden oh no John man so fast
John man is really really fast and I
can't move okay
stay focused now Oh John man is coming
at me hard here okay that opened up
really quick pin this night bring my
queen out castle get on the h-file just
take this night gonna take and get dark
square issues hang on
get over here
what does that even do what does that
even do what am i doing
okay let's shut down that's very scary I
got to defend this I have a scary check
done I aah
the Knights gonna kill me oh he's gonna
kill me he's gonna kill me he's gonna
kill me I gotta get rid of him he's too
tricky he's way too tricky he's in a pin
though he's in a pin now hang on I could
kick that rook away my rook my Knights
defended tricky night stay stay stay
focused oh hang on Oh tricky Knights
it's a Ford I got it those two pawns are
passed passed pawns are fast pawns
remember that okay hang on get going now
they resigned back determined that was a
big win one 1072 third Knight got tricky
so quick right there where was it d6
fortunately I had a pin there
counterpunch I had to do a counter punch
that tricky night this one's not
starting I I'm afraid to go away and do
some homework about a top player because
the game might start I might get some
points for it not starting I'm at 110
John man's probably creeping back up on
me eighty eight eighty five eighty come
on this isn't starting
ah man I don't like the looks of things
here I'm having actually some technical
issues with my stream I'm getting a
memory is getting crushed right now that
wasn't doing this last time what's going
on are they gonna start oh man this is
not good technical issues - it's not
starting there was an error no give me
points yes they gave me ten okay there's
still 13 minutes remaining you throw
this age pond down okay that's going to
be a problem I want to get to f6 get
this night out of there f6 here I come
f6 here I come
here we go f6 it's happening with check
and support this night right here
everything is defended clean check I
just block and then I dropped that now I
don't okay palm push and response to
that these pawns are very strong very
very strong whoa I don't want to go in
that direction let's get rid of that guy
he's too good okay let's support my
Center this Knight is defending this
pawn and missed that it was an easy one
to miss can take this pawn with check
and I'm defending the knight and okay
what's this queen going to be up to
let's just trade let's just trade it oh
I had me I had me Knight f6 was me ah
man that would that's exactly what I
needed I didn't do it though did I it's
still winning but I should have already
had this one in the bag he's pinned
don't take pin pieces even if there
might be a scary discovery type of
situation okay hang on here hang on he's
still pinned he's not going anywhere
don't take pin pieces attack them there
we go
what's this King up to 13 seconds
there's plenty of time at this game I
just feel like this is all just a waste
of time right now no HS isn't a waste of
time is it looking for me
there we go back to chairman 140 108
how's my computer doing a little scary
10 minutes remaining
VIP I'm gonna play against the VIP okay
let's try this I gotta throw these in
every now and then I just can't I can't
help it I just can't help it you know
what I'm talking about every now and
then dark square weaknesses maybe I
should have considered taking that night
in a castle hang on okay I'm on edge too
difficult to defend not being defended
I want my queen on the h-file take that
bishop deadly fork deadly for
ah they missed that trickiness drop my
clean back so she's defended that my
nights too good I'm gonna hang on to him
I can support him right here I have that
covered
I'm up a piece that helps to just get
this pond rolling now how about this get
this night out here
and then I play d5 d5 coming up okay
let's just get this out get rid of
pieces trade trade trade trade I'm on
see up a rook where are those trades
here no matter what I just get a flight
square in or just push my pawn he's past
trade trade
just get behind the past Pond and push
that's with check and now the queen is
back she's back and that's not me
neither is that this is the back
determine 1/16 128 160 130 less than 9
minutes right after this turn I think I
have to restart the stream otherwise my
computer's gonna blow up not good never
a good thing
d3 Queen e1 Queen g3 stay out of that
sneaky stuff it's not coming with check
anymore so that's just a free pot I'm
gonna hang out in my bishop get the
center in although this Knight has to be
removed whoa
now that was sneaky that was a sneak
attack I'm a knight right here I get a
piece two pieces and having a problem
right now you one to a5 that's an issue
might lose anywhere I just take here pre
move that they resigned back to
tournament 180 I just had 180 didn't I
did I not get points for that or did I
have 160 I need to take a peek at the
computer will I be able to finish yeah I
should be able to finish just enough
juice left here just enough resources
barely I have no idea why it's doing
this to me I should have done that they
Castle there they're there in time to
defend f2 yep
so I need to get out of Knight a for
stuff and in disguise we have potential
there's potential hang on stay on this
diagonal there is no night camping out
here I could grab hang on
I'm gonna kick this night away and then
jump in here this is reminding me of the
Siberian trap as well as the fishing
pole kick this night away night here
Queen here is losing
okay so night here I'm looking to remove
that night oh I missed that move take
with the rook I want to stand this
diagonal but my
isn't there to watch over each - now
let's get back over there look I insist
oh now I could be taking the Queen the
knight is there get out of there night
this is still working
surprisingly it's still working tricky
tricky stuff you have to play g3 less
than 10 seconds to figure it out grab
this and then grab that piece back don't
even take there's no time I'm on each -
each - is it gonna happen no time for
each - 201 61 56 minutes remaining bit
that bit squared again main line Carol
let's just take that time that time all
right we're gonna we're gonna be trading
army we are trading we're not going to
be we just are okay
what's how do you assess this position
things will change very quickly but what
thing is standing out to you right now
if you said Queen side majority give
yourself a high five keep yourself a
high five I have a four on three four
and three can I put that to use not with
that guy around he's gonna be be very
delicate right now very delicate okay
let's get these guys going - vs1
forks forks the knight is cooked
Queen trade simplify stuff that pond is
going down I think I almost Mouse
slipped to Dean King position my king
wants to be on c4 my rook can not be
removed that pod can't have pressure
placed on them as soon as I'm defending
my seat on my bishop is free to move now
he's moving I could give some checks
here maybe some discoveries grab these
pawns check probably King here and then
there's Bishop stuff on e6 and in this
direction as well and then I just get
rolling his pod cannot be stopped they
resigned back determine 221 84 minutes
33 seconds oh this is a top guy this is
the top guy I don't know um he's getting
pushed around a little bit though he
went reverse build a center come here
and then drop back no I don't have to
drop back if Bishop blocked I was gonna
drop back stay right here
stop this Knight move uh-uh okay I want
to be able to take those guys out okay
structural change I could have a passed
pawn passed pawn where does my knight
wanna be clamped down here my knight
wants to be right there on B I'm okay
with that pawn push okay oh my light
squares oh no light square issues my
knight wants to be on c5 I have to get
rid of this guy I'm pretty sure I need
to get rid of that guy no I got to stop
that stuff right here I got a pin point
that pawn takes here and then I'm on c4
I gotta open stuff up definitely have to
open stuff up okay I'm on this right
here now pawn is hard to defend now
that's a pin oh don't take pin pieces no
it's not pinned anymore take unpin
pieces take on pinned pieces I want to
take this so I don't have to deal with a
thorn on g6 very important detail drop
back to defend my seventh but now I just
have control over both files
pin this bishop and then drop over here
I'm on this pawn pin right here as well
takes here I'm just gonna take simplify
stuff 18 seconds I get this pie it still
just can't be easy can it okay now it
can't be okay oh I just dropped a pun
why'd I do that I have to do oh my
goodness I just dropped a rook what am i
doing oh is it still gonna be a draw now
it is ah man that was such an easy win
wasn't it oh man 3 to 20 I opened oh
there's a window open now for a second
place guy oh I didn't even see this
sneaky King move back to basics man King
moves it tax your rug what's that
question you're supposed to ask yourself
what question wasn't I asking myself
what's the threat man what's the threat
I forgot about that you can't forget
about that question it's the most
important question in chess
believe me believe me I'm not making
this stuff up ah man that was so I can't
explain it
I'm not moving either this Knight has to
go I think Wow way to just open up this
position I'm gonna get crushed I'm gonna
get mated oh my goodness I'm getting
mated
Oh could I somehow save this
I have bishop blocks oh I should have
done that oh my goodness I'm so scared
oh my goodness I'm so scared right now
oh man I got a run in hi I got it hide
over here this nights gonna kill me ah
this nights killing me oh man I'm so
scared right now you have no idea oh my
goodness I'm so dead oh I got made it
all down to 48 118 ah oh man I trying to
kill her lost me I can't end it like
this
this is this is the holiday season this
is the holiday season where are my gifts
oh man this is the holiday season I
don't even have any chance you ever have
any chance that's my computer gonna die
Oh can I get a mate no I could get a
piece oh man did this just go to Oh
this is their Colin it they're calling
it that's game second place oh oh that
was brutal that was brutal that was a
terrible ending oh oh man
he was looking so smooth wasn't it good
games are